- three - what that rope in who's to
blame News everybody but me submitted by
instigate bartender was arrested after
serving a man too much alcohol before he
shot several people wholly arrested by
Dignam me thank you yes I know this this
happened in Texas back in 2017 you guys
remember we talked about this man who
was very drunk
and he went to a football party yep the
guy was wearing the green corduroys he
shot everybody else I remember
everything
with the floppy vans yep yes it walks he
attacked his ex-wife and seven of their
friends in his former home in Plano
Texas it's happened September 2017 its
Plano huh that's where it came from
oh really from Dallas what we know is a
suburb of Dallas I don't know anything
about the Texas that's where you grew up
in Plano plain old Texas yeah plain old
Texas that's what I thought when he told
me he was from there I thought it was a
joke and I was I started laughing like
ha ha Plano it's he's like no like good
American joke good American joke I was
born there too but I'll speak the
language stupid yeah I thought it was
[ __ ] hilarious
black ah no Texas anyway this is the the
bartender name is Lindsay it's not her
fault she was just doing her job
it actually is her fault it's her
[ __ ] fault like she does her [ __ ]
fault god damn it it's so bad yeah cuz I
heard that if someone tells you to not
serve their friend drinks or if you see
that someone's obviously too drunk you
should show you're supposed to refuse
well but she wanted the money so the
thing is she actually knew the guy so
his name is Spencer was the one so he
went to the bar where she works and she
was serving him drinks and like they she
was actually supposed to go to that
party that he went to
[Music]
accomplices no so what I'm just reacting
to the horror wait that's your reaction
to the war that's what I go that mean
you don't get that feeling no I go oh
like it's so sad for Horace for a
horrible situation yeah I'm just like oh
my god oh yeah yeah that's shock that's
weird but I miss job huh yes
surveillance footage she feels better
when I expressed that it's an angry call
to another like 10 second I know this
Dan oh do you yeah why don't you take
dancing TIFF can you tell me the article
verbal Dan you wanna know what's going
on step back I'm gonna be tucked over I
really wanna know what's happening tell
you tell me please I didn't do you think
I wanted okay it erupted you tell your
daddy directory so surveillance footage
showed that Spencer appeared highly
intoxicated he was unsteady steady on
his feet and he was running into tables
and walking sideways like a crab wish
that he was doing one of these
yessuh Lindy had texted a fellow
bartender while serving Spencer saying
Spencer has a big knife on the bar and
is spinning it and just asked for his
tab and said I have to go do some dirty
work psycho oh that while still serving
him [ __ ] what's wrong with this whoa
come on girl yeah she was trained to
identify signs of intoxication another
thing that he did was he produced a
pistol from his front pocket and put it
on the table produced it house that's
why they wrote it hold it out why does
he produce that's just like that legally
proper term yeah I think so like you
produced a knife you produced a guy oh I
never heard of that
yeah so it's against Texas law to bring
a firearm into a bar
of course then this girl just ignored
all these signs yes like I've been
trained that looks familiar
were there no other bartenders it was
just her I don't know but it's also
difficult because the dudes her friend
right so imagine like one of our friends
comes in we would probably give them a
little bit more leeway to even though
they're tripping you know but at the
same time if it was a friend I'd be like
no all your Joe [ __ ] put a knife on
my bar get out of here fool my gun she
could have been scared such a terrible
friend dude hell no dude such a
emulation for sheree something made it
my friend came in sad and drunk he was
spitting a knife I would spit my knife
on the table with it I would do yep I
start sword fighting like that though
like play fighting I would leave his ass
in there and I was just trying to take
care of them I could drink some more
while like I'd keep him there you're
such a good person
terrible initially that's why we don't
have drunk friends so when Spencer left
the bar she contacted the police oh so
she did her job yeah so she got arrested
yes so that's why people are saying are
like her lawyers like oh it's shameful
of the Plano Police Department to go
after the person who was vital and
trying to stop their horrific events
from that evening but like the law says
you shouldn't you can't be serving
alcohol to people that are already
highly intoxicated or if they're not
mentally stable she did [ __ ] up but I
think she was scared his blood alcohol
level was four times over the legal
limit if someone was at the bar and they
had like the gun knife and all that did
they're like also like give me more
drink and you're like sure and then you
give him that but I think she should
have called the cops while he was there
but then the friend element probably
[ __ ] it all up yeah because it's hard
to call the cops on your friend yeah
because like how many times you like you
know when you're younger and you go
party with your friends and they're
drunk you know like hey are you driving
and they're like yeah and then they're
like all wobbly I don't think I should
drive and you could only tell them like
about 20 times everyone tells about 20
times but if they grab the keys you
start getting hella aggressive I'm
driving matter what then you're like all
right no you don't go all right yeah you
don't do that you've Mart's never done
that oh no I was younger
that happens a lot like especially if
they're not my friends friend you know
when you go to parties like 50 people
that's David's friends friends friend
I'm just like I I just do my like three
three degrees of separation' friend
duties if it's David I'm a tackle his
ass the punch I make out with them
because when you're you when you're
younger I won't do it
you're on a house party and [ __ ] all you
do is shake your hand go that guy's
gonna get in an accident [ __ ] that guy
try I do my duty I try to do it yeah
yeah we you don't play you don't but you
don't like go out of the line for your
brother's friends co-workers friend like
you know that person you see him like
for the past 10 years
you're not gonna tackle that fool so I
can a little bit I can see where she's
coming from where she's probably just
like well I tried and this is the guy
that comes in and act crazy yeah they
can't be like oh the reason why he
killed everybody is because he was drunk
and it's all your fault
it's like man it could have been
anything she's getting arrested not
because he killed someone she's just
getting arrested because criminal
negligence right yeah for serving when
he was filled is such like a gray area
that is the law like the law states that
it is considered criminal negligence for
sure
I mean that is the law for sure but like
when we all drink
who isn't four times the legal limit
well then I guess you know I mean it's
like it's just like what's reality
what's the law and I think you gotta
take both and every single person that
crashes after leaving a bar the bar
should get in trouble following this
logic yeah crashing is a criminal
offense though nobody driving under the
influence and the bartender that's
serving them even they though they know
they're probably over the legal limit
but still giving them drinks that's all
right because the bartender doesn't
necessarily know that people came in
there with a car yeah see that's why
it's just so many that's for her maybe
she wasn't in a position where even
there's to her friends she didn't know
that he came in with a gun and a knife
and then you put a gun on the table it's
not like my first reaction would be call
the police in front of that person homie
get them out get him out honestly at my
own life sake like I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah cuz what if he finds breaking the
law I need them out of my life zone you
know yeah how come they're not putting
that into a factory like there's like a
certain level of threat that was present
when she maybe they threw that
the window when they saw that at that
time stamp when she's texting her other
friends so go you know it's like all
[ __ ] you didn't feel like you were
fearing for your life because look
here's this next but I don't know she's
because if we were off like like friends
at the bar right and then I don't know
like you guys weren't here and then we
saw David come in and then like he has a
knife and then I'm texting boy like oh
my god this food David's [ __ ] acting
like a fool right now with with a knife
like I don't know what he's gonna do
with it but he we always know him as the
violent crazy buddy you know I think the
text says anything if she's scared or
36s yeah yeah well maybe that's held the
other side of the lawyer yeah I mean
it's just stupid like how they're
building up a case against the wrong
person yeah well I mean the guy that did
think he committed he's already been he
killed seven people
yes hey and he also killed themselves
it's just one of those things words he
was killing a shooter both killed in a
shootout with the cops yeah it's one of
those things where people want justice
and they gotta put somebody in trouble
yeah feels like make the person that's
closest to it all the family members of
the victims they filed a lawsuit against
her and the bar for negligence
I would file a [ __ ] lawsuit against
that family because I'm like my why the
[ __ ] did you raise a son like this yeah
victims there's eight that sucks when
did this happen there's eight people
that died what a multicultural group of
friends I didn't know they even got
keemstar in their shoes oh it was so
ex-wife and seven oh yeah they were aged
from 22 to 33 just all they're missing
now is the Asian Asian friend I know
they're not that includes that's all
we're talking about it that's right but
see that's the thing too like they're
going after somebody to kind of is a
band-aid to cover up some type of pain
yeah they're feeling because they lost
their family members but you're trying
to make somebody hurt that's not gonna
really heal you that girl goes to jail
it doesn't fix anything yeah and it
doesn't take away from the fact that
advice were taken not by that girl by
but this other person so yeah the
parents should put themself in jail
instead of suing someone else for the
actions of their own son yeah put it
like this and even though this is I'm
being I'm making assumptions here if it
wasn't her he would have got alcohol
somewhere else he was still gonna do it
that's what I'm saying
yeah alcohol didn't make him do it
didn't make him do that he was gonna do
it at either way he was gonna get that
alcohol he could have saved money by
going to a liquor store and buying a
bottle himself and he's been reckless
there he was like [ __ ] my credit card he
was already out there for that so wasn't
on her yeah so now she is facing a year
in jail $500 fine or both I don't think
she should get any other that's just
terrible dude I mean I don't mind if I
mean I get all assumptions we don't want
details but like she throw a monetary of
financial fine on somebody you know to
me and set an example so that you pay
the price if you are in that situation
again you're like oh slice yeah you're
like I'm supposed to report this earlier
I'm supposed to pay more attention sure
but like he had a gun out the bar also
lots lost its license to sell alcohol
that's so wrong that is yeah it's so
[ __ ] wrong yeah other people are
paying the price for something else that
some dude was already gonna yeah yeah
[Music]